what's your name William William yeah
nice to meet you nice to meet you too I
love Ghana I love you oh no you don't
love you that way maybe in time that
would develop a gastroenterologist
gastroenterologist in the action in
training though how do I feel and feel
healthy you have any change no husband's
no no change my bowel habits I still use
a toilet
I want a coconut hi how do you know me
where you from I'm from you're from
Ghana
how do you know me
[Applause]
next here this is a problem you can't
stop this he got in trouble
again this is also problematic now this
is also a problem we didn't do anything
but it's still you should get rid of
this one do you like the hair it's it's
scary very nice to meet you you were
very beautiful but I am married it's
good right
and then this is good been doing it
right this okay you want me to stop like
he wants me to stop Oh God I want to
work on a shirt what do you think how do
I look you think I look done in you need
to go it's called LensCrafters I think
it's very cool that here in Ghana they
honor all the great leaders Malcolm X
Bob Marley you have of course dr. Martin
Luther King jr. and
yeah do that again
see ona n-no no what's that
fruit I'll get get a lot of passion if I
eat the passion fruits my wife will be
happy because I'll have the energy no
but I'll be good for me
[Applause]